fans of the show know we love bud light
seltzer and you know what we love more
than bud light seltzer when they sponsor
the show they are the presenting sponsor
you know about bud light seltzer it's a
delicious hard seltzer from bud light
with no bud light in it each one is only
100 calories 5 alcohol by volume and
gluten free and now they get the perfect
flavors for summer with the bud light
seltzer lemonade variety pack and the
brand new bud light seltzer ice tea
variety pack you can try them together
which christian did the other day and
make your ideal alcoholic arnold palmer
with a bud light seltzer iced tea and
lemonade mix pack or dive into the good
vibes of yesteryear with the retro
summer pack and retro summer icicles
there's that cherry limeade and that's
my favorite flavors and you know when
you can combine there's a peach iced tea
and lemonade you combine those together
get a peach arnold palmer stay tuned to
hear more about bud light seltzer's
newest offerings and a little more about
us and our summer memories later in the
show but now the show
[Music]
this is a little bit strange we were
going to give a disclaimer because we're
going to be talking about some
psychedelic drugs some psychoactive
plants and substances that
in many cases are illegal but are
starting to become
more legalized and the conversation
about these drugs is becoming more
normalized so our disclaimer has turned
into a non-disclaimer disclaimer however
if there are young children listening
then
i would say there should still be a
disclaimer okay so it is a disclaimer
technique disclaimer's back on okay all
right well that was short-lived the
non-disclaimer so yeah that's a good
point okay little kids
stop listening i hate saying that
because it'd be great to have little
kids listening you don't have to be mean
about it no no no i'm not chiding i'm
not like shaming stop listening but i
didn't say it like that i said maybe a
stoplight how about this parents who
have kids
just know that you have the option of at
your discretion shielding your children
from this episode or exposing them to it
and then helping normalize a whole
generation of kids the way our parents
weren't normalized to it ball is in your
court
here's the show
life
[Music]
you're listening to life to short i am
your uh medium heights host justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
with me as always is my also medium
height you know both have to be medium
height uh co-host christian
christian yeah yeah wait why why are you
saying you have medium height well i'm
i'm of a medium of an average build so
what i don't know i just thought it'd be
sort of it just came out it was just
apropos nothing i guess so life is short
oh it's maybe it's just
sparked okay my friend uh knew the show
was called life is short for
a couple weeks now and she just uh
she just put it together that was justin
long with justin long you got a lot of
friends
you got a lot of friends really yeah
why are you upset about it no you you
keep talking about your friends on the
show lately and it's nice
i can tell you've become more social
yeah i have a little bit i'm getting out
of the bubble yeah you're stepping out
well i'm double vaxxed i feel like yeah
double that
yeah um speaking of vax the vaccine
that's a form of a drug right oh sure
yeah uh synthesized yes but what is your
speaking of drugs what is your
experience with mushrooms because we're
going to talk a lot about yes shrooms
psilocybin some cool people call them
shrooms yeah i'm not cool enough to call
them shrooms
have you ever had an experience i have
yeah i have i've had um i've had a
couple experiences
right yeah you're not stranger to the
shroom
game i
really enjoyed my experiences with them
to the point where i
often wonder why i haven't had more
because i really enjoyed it i know the
first time i did it was in palm springs
in the desert in a very peaceful
location with my friend and my friends
too oh yeah wow you're talking a lot
about your friends it was fascinating
and like it you know what it felt like
you're like jim morrison it felt like
being really stoned without any of the
paranoia or the weirdness of being said
and like the memory loss you know
sometimes when you get really stoned
you're having a good time but you forget
your train of thought oh yeah what
happened two seconds from moment to
moment yeah but this had none of that
this was like right there's a clarity
stuff all the fun stuff with a totally
clear mind and i remember things colors
changing that's what i remember but i
didn't see you know i didn't have like
wild hallucinations i just things were
enhanced that that's a good point that's
a good way of saying it yeah in hands
they were um
amplified i think colors and that the
last one the last time i remember doing
it was uh at marfa
at the el cosmico
resort resort i mean it's a airstream
trailers uh friend of ours runs that
place a great place um but i remember
the stars there got the sky being just
brilliant i mean more so than it had
been
uh in in my recent memory but i've never
done other hallucinogenic drugs i've
never done lsd for example
and i've always been scared
yes well because we grew up during like
a time where drugs were the war on drugs
was at its peak and there was a lot of
anti-acid anti-lsd propaganda floating
around and it was very pervasive and it
was it affected me i know i remember
being in health class and
uh hearing all those horror stories that
i'm sure many of you did so why are we
talking about this but well our guest
today is doing a lot i think to help
change that conversation to destigmatize
yes when it comes to
psilocybin and other psychotropic drugs
i guess
to psychoactive plants it's really he
talks about the history of it he talks
about the politics
but he also approaches it from a very
botanist centric point of view it's it's
a fascinating book that he wrote his
name our special guest today uh a very
brilliant man and uh he's written such
fascinating books our guest is michael
pollan and to him to a lesser degree but
really interesting to me he is the
brother of tracy pollen who is the wife
of monk and j fox yeah that should be
more of a footnote he knows he himself
is
incredibly accomplished i shouldn't have
said that he you know it's okay but it's
important to me it's worth noting that
it's a footnote yes yeah it's a real
foot it's definitely footnote worthy he
is a brilliant author and
one of our leading voices in nutrition
yeah he wrote the omnivores dilemma
his recent book is called business just
that just came out yes just kidding this
is your mind on plans god is it good
it's so fascinating but it's it's a good
companion piece to his uh previous book
that came out in 2018 which is called
how to change your mind i think it's
about and it's about psychedelics and
the effect that they have on the mind
and how much research is being done uh
in terms of mental health and harnessing
the power of these plants the drugs that
come from these plants really
fascinating truly i can't stress enough
how good these books are and um it would
probably help to have some knowledge of
them before you hear the interview but
hopefully not necessarily um i remember
when we first started doing this podcast
a couple years ago
we were talking about before it even
started before we uh aired an episode i
remember talking about what types of
people we'd like to have on the show
yeah and we said you know obviously
actors musicians and thinkers
and wrestlers
yes i remember you saying
you know i i want to not just have
actors because that might get a little
boring but um you know it'd be great to
have people like you know someone like
michael pollan for example i remember it
was the very first
example you cited like who a amazing
guest would be on the show and we
finally got him yeah i'm so grateful
that we do short years later yeah that's
true i've always we've been wanting him
for a long time i didn't realize i had
said that explicitly
all those i remember those lo those many
years ago but um yeah we did get him on
and it was a white whale yeah oh man is
he interesting and i was so excited to
talk to him so i'm excited for you to
hear it uh coming up the only
frustrating thing about this was that we
had only an hour when we had a very
limited time and at one point i think
you'll hear uh our internet went out uh
where we were in connecticut we had a
little storm so god was that frustrating
because i wanted every minute he was you
know i couldn't get enough and so
uh hopefully you'll enjoy this my
conversation
with the brilliant michael pollan
life could be a dream
hello hello again should boom and open
we'll meet again
[Music]
there's so much to talk to you about
there's too much um and i i i'm having a
hard time figuring out a way in but
first i want to tell you what a huge fan
i am of yours and how much i enjoyed
your work thank you very much i really
appreciate that that's great um
and this new book is uh is
it continues to to be uh continues your
your excellence in
in the reporting of nutrition and the
mind and it's called this is your mind
on plants um we're gonna talk so much
about it uh but i i first want to get to
your last book how to change your mind
which i'm in the midst of reading um
how much of this new book this is your
mind on plants was born out of your
research uh doing how to change your
mind i mean was it was it just a direct
uh was it a natural progression
you know it's not a sequel um
but there were aspects of the
psychedelic story i felt i hadn't
addressed
so for example
how to change your mind stuck pretty
close to the scientific research
and uh didn't really look at the fact
that uh the whole field of psychedelic
therapy which is now getting
you know so much uh uh
research backing it up and and general
approval uh is founded on uh a base of
indigenous knowledge um you know that
that people in the americas were using
psychedelics to heal
for as much as 6 000 years and uh and i
wanted to look at that so there's a a
long section on mescaline which is the
um the chemical produced by the peyote
cactus and the san pedro cactus and is
probably the oldest psychedelic in use
so in that sense it's you know it's
filling a hole left by the other book
but both books grow out of my
fascination with
the plants and fungi that have for some
crazy reason evolved to change human
consciousness
um
i mean it it's a very it's a very weird
idea when you think about it that that
that plant several plants and several
fungi
have
evolved to make precisely the
the molecule necessary to unlock human
consciousness and change it
that's what was fascinating too and the
botanical evolution of those uh
of those molecules that unlock that and
they're not poisonous you talk about how
they're they can't be
lethal certainly not lethal to to other
animals but they have to alter them
somehow they have to prevent them from
coming back to the plants can you talk a
little bit about that how that evolution
came to be and and why plants produce
these these
properties so i mean the honest answer
is we don't completely know we have some
interesting theories um but most of the
chemicals that change consciousness uh
started out as pesticides as you know
plants can't move they can't run away so
they have to do everything
staying put and so what tools can you
use if you can't move well chemical
chemistry and the plant plants have
become the masters of neurochemistry um
and so many of these they're usually
alkaloids is the kind of chemical they
are in most of these plants they uh are
toxic to animals at some dose caffeine
is a pesticide for example right that
was fascinating and they administered
their doses that certain bees
increases the the pollen well with
pollinating abilities what's interesting
is that something that at a high dose
can be toxic like caffeine at a low dose
can have all these attractive effects
yes so um so plants need to defend
themselves with these chemicals but if
you're a plant and you come up with a
chemical that actually is lethal at
small doses and you kill your pests
that's actually not the best strategy
because those chemicals will encourage
resistance in the populations
exactly and so then suddenly your your
your brilliant chemical defense is
rendered useless
much better strategy to just kind of
discombobulate the brain of your pest
make them forget where they saw that
leaf make them um act crazy and start
dancing madly so that some bird might
come and pick you know pick up that
insect and kill it that's incredible my
insight into this happened because i had
a cat with a catnip problem um many
years ago and i planted catnip in my
vegetable garden which was fenced
and every evening frank was his name he
would follow me down into the vegetable
garden when i was going to pick a salad
or something for dinner and he'd look up
at me and i realized he didn't remember
where the catnip was oh he remembered
that there was catnip oh my god he was
so disoriented yeah so i'd have to pick
him up and show him the catnip and he'd
get completely [ __ ] up and you know
roll around
and then again he he lost track of where
it was so
for a um
i realized for a plant that's a pretty
good strategy oh yeah
mess with the minds of your pests rather
than kill them and so you approach this
book from uh you approach it from a
viewpoint of three different plants
which is the the poppy uh opiates and
then caffeine
which i often don't think of as i you
know i you don't typically think of that
as a drug a drug and you talk about
going off of it for i think three months
and yeah i want to hear about that but
um and then the third one the
hallucinogenics uh you talk about that
you mentioned uh peyote and
um
did you so you actually had then you
felt like you needed to have first-hand
experience with each of these drugs and
how did that come well i that's kind of
what i do in my journalism i really like
putting myself in the middle of the
story um
and
kind of there's a point of view you can
acquire by doing something for the first
time that's very powerful um i learned
this when i a long time ago my parents
gave me a copy of george plimpton's book
paper lion where he played
quarterback for the detroit lions you
know complete amateur do you remember
this book is a wonderful book of course
and i realized then and i was 13 when i
read it that
he could see football in a way that the
most experienced players could not
because he was doing it for the first
time he had that sense of awe and wonder
that you only have once in life and um
so very often i mean going back to i
remember writing a piece on genetically
modified crops that i i planted one in
my garden uh a monsanto potato to see
what would happen and and then i when i
was writing about the cattle industry i
bought a cow and followed it through the
whole food system for omnivores dilemma
and um so i've often found that um it's
useful to use your first person in that
in that really intimate way
so for yeah so for opiates i definitely
tried what i grew
for
caffeine as you pointed out the
challenge was abstaining not indulging
because i am a caffeine addict i've got
a cup of green tea right here and i had
coffee a little while ago
and then mescaline i was very eager to
try it because
everyone i interviewed in the
psychedelic community from my last book
when i asked them what's your favorite
psychedelic they all said mescaline yeah
really yeah yeah you never see it it's
not around very much it's hard to find
um but they
wow even even somebody like you you talk
about rick doblin
you talk about bob the great
you know everything that happened in
2006 uh i guess i'm not there yet um but
i'm hearing a lot about mdm
mdma and
lsd certainly about albert hofmann it's
fascinating you also detail their
experiences with it which um i found was
a really useful it was useful to know
the history of yeah well albert
hoffman's history is really interesting
i mean he really has the first acid trip
right yeah because he invented uh lsd
and um uh you know that's commemorated
every year on i think it's april 19th
which is now a holiday called bicycle
day because
he uh he he tried it in the lab
accidentally and realized he had to get
home and so he had this very rickety
bike ride down the cobblestones of
basil or whatever city he was in um
so uh
yeah so i thought something interesting
too and i you keep returning to this
there this seems to come up a lot is the
connection
of um is losing the ego is the the
distancing from the ego and the
connection to nature too how what a huge
role that plays in in the benefits of
something like psychedelics and he had
that in his trip he said the world was
as if newly created uh he went he was in
his garden everything's sparkled there's
something so beautiful about that and my
favorite
experiences with with drugs like that um
are ones where i i often find myself
really connecting to nature in a way
that
i i don't typically uh yeah every day
you talk about that doing that with with
judith i think um
yeah though i had an experience uh on
psilocybin uh and i was in my garden in
connecticut and it was the most
remarkable thing because all these
plants that i live with um
suddenly had a point of view had had a
had their own
personhood subject hood
and they were returning my gaze and and
they were more alive than they'd ever
been i mean we have trouble connecting
with plants because they operate on a
different time scale than we do right
they they don't they move around they
move slowly but they move and they
respond to their environment they're
really intelligent
uh they have strategies to cope with all
sorts of situations
but on
psilocybin all that which is you know i
understood intellectually i could feel
emotionally
and there's actually been some research
suggesting that people's uh connection
to nature changes after a single
psilocybin trip
um
the psychologists have have a survey or
a score for for your degree of nature
connectedness how much do you feel
you're part of nature or that you stand
outside nature and those scores go up uh
after uh psilocybin and which is very
interesting and and makes some people
think that you know this is very useful
for
teaching people a more environmentally
conscious consciousness
yeah yeah and that it is um
that there there does seem to be uh
an enrichment i mean that that alone
when you were talking about all this
people might wonder well what is the
point i mean what is the
what's culturally what's the point um
and there's something so enriching about
that idea to me um because nature is of
course yeah yeah no i mean that's one
thing i mean i think there are cultural
benefits
to people using psychedelics i mean not
everybody they're certainly not for
everybody but they
you know in certain minds the encounter
of that molecule and that mind leads to
breakthroughs leads to new ideas leads
to new metaphors i mean you think about
the whole history of
of artists who've who've used you know
whether it's opiates or cannabis
and that it was really essential to
their creation to their creativity and
and there are a number of scientists too
who will tell you that they had
breakthroughs on lsd that um carrie
mullis the inventor of pcr the the
technologies for multiplying uh dna
which is used whenever we get a cova
test
um
he it was on an lsd trip that he was
able to kind of as he described it go in
and sit on the molecule and understand
how to multiply it
and um so in certain minds i mean look
most people who use drugs
the ideas that they have are pretty
lousy you know and or banal you know but
in but
every so often that encounter um
produces something that's enormously
valuable to our culture and maybe that's
one of the reasons that you know
drug takers have not been eliminated by
natural selection i mean you know
because because there's there's lots of
negatives to it too obviously people can
you know overdose people can um
[Music]
have accidents you know their judgment
is impaired but you would think if if it
was all so bad that drug takers would
have been eliminated by evolution and
they have not been that's true um
fortunately that brings me back to the
um the connection the idea of this
child-like wonder i mean that keeps
coming up too and yeah and a child brain
uh and and what happens to our brains
that it inhibit that kind of thinking
that kind of curiosity uh the the
wonderment of the world um
you said something really interesting in
in your in the book um
in how to change your mind you say
habits are useful uh
they're they're to you know so you don't
have to spend time on complex mental
operations but they they relieve us of
the need to stay awake to the world i
thought that was really interesting yeah
so habits are like algorithms you know
they help us navigate situations um
based on what happened last time or the
time before so they're based on memory
um
whereas uh you know being present is
based on what's happening right here and
now
and habits and habitual thinking take us
off that frontier of the present and one
of the things that psychedelics do is
return us to that frontier that um in a
way some of the the habitual thinking is
disabled
and there's a very nice uh metaphor that
um a psychologist i interviewed for the
book uh gave me which is she says there
are two kinds of consciousness there's
spotlight consciousness which is very
focused
and is able to block out everything and
and concentrate on a problem that's very
linear very rational and then there's
spotlight then there's lantern
consciousness which is taking in
information from all sides is easily
distractible and of course that's
children's consciousness right before
you're five or six you can't sit in a
chair and focus on anything
that's why we don't send kids to school
till they're you know four five or six
um
and that kind of consciousness is very
good for learning about the world
um exploring whereas the other
consciousness is for exploiting for
getting things done
and it's that transition really that
marks the transition from childhood to
adulthood
and one theory of psychedelics is that
they return us to lantern consciousness
oh wow that the kind of thinking that
they promote um is not so directed and
allows you to take in sensory
information from all directions
and achieve a kind of childlike openness
to experience that is that most of us
have lost and i think that's one of the
reasons that they can be psychedelics
are so powerful for for adults
and unlocking the potential for
innovation like you said you know
whether it's well creativity creativity
comes out i mean
what we understand about creativity is
you need both kinds of consciousness
initially you need the very open
exploratory
associative consciousness um but then
once you've created something you need
to have the critical faculty to is it
any good or is it [ __ ] and how do i make
it better right and and so it's it's a
rhythm between these two um yeah and i
think that there
there was some research done on
psychedelics and creativity in the 70s
it was very promising uh it needs to be
done now with more rigorous uh methods
and there are some scientists who want
to work on it and i i think it could
really teach us some fascinating things
about creativity it sounds like it and
like you said there's been in the last
couple of years that's been
an explosion of um you know this in the
scientific community seeing the benefits
of certainly on mental health and uh
with lsd and some of these drugs why you
talk about this in the book but but why
do you think it was that um it was in
the dark for so long it was kind of put
to rest it was hibernating i guess uh
well it was suppressed
i mean it really was suppressed um
beginning with the nixon administration
um which you know really launches the
drug war in 1970 and and lsd is a main a
big target of the drug war
you know um a quote came out i i have
this in the new book um dan baum a
journalist was writing a book on the
drug war and he went and interviewed
john ehrlichman after he got out of
prison for watergate and uh he was
nixon's domestic policy advisor
and he and
baum asked him about the drug war and
and um
erlickman was incredibly candid and he
said
the nixon administration had two enemies
one was black people and the other was
hippies
and we knew if we could criminalize
their drugs lsd and cannabis we would
have the tools to harass them to go into
their communities to discredit them
and uh you know it was not about he
basically said it wasn't about public
health it was about politics
wow and so you know nixon was very
concerned that lsd was behind the
refusal of many american boys to to
fight in vietnam
and he may have been right i mean if you
think about it historically um
usually when you send an 18 year old off
to war um they go
without question right and there was
this weird thing going on in the 60s
where a great many american boys said
i'm not going um
and nixon
thought that the drugs and lsd in
particular were part of the reason and
he may well have been right well you say
that in your book too that that's that
was a new frontier for um
a rite of passage that typically you
know an adult a boy would become an
adult and they would fold into society
whereas you know with the advent of lsd
and and the counter culture the rise of
the counter culture there was this sense
that they were creating their own
thing that they were thinking
differently thinking uh outside
the box
yeah no and lsd does
certainly encourage
uh original thought um you know people
often have new perspectives
they're
less inclined to believe messages from
institutions right and to think for
themselves you you call it shaking the
snow globe i love that yeah that was uh
one of the neuroscientists used that
phrase for what happens that the that
you shake the snow globe with a
psychedelic and then when the snow
settles it's in a different different
alignment
[Music]
this segment is brought to you by bud
light seltzer's new retro summer pack
what do you think of when you think of
retro i guess a bygone era you know what
i remember from summer's past what i
remember
doing shout out fairfield teen theater
summer summer theater with you but as
fun as those times were they were
missing one
critical thing i would say vibes no they
were good vibes they were good vibes
they had good vibes they were good tunes
for sure uh-huh
what else do you have a summer at
barbecues they had parade parades there
was a parade oh you know what it was
missing bud light seltzer bingo i miss
my childhood and i know you miss yours
but here's the good thing about being an
adult now we get to enjoy these good
summer vibes because we're right in the
middle of summer now this is great this
is like prime summer we get to enjoy
adult beverages namely
bud light seltzer and what's very
exciting
these new bud light seltzer retro summer
icicles they're so delicious i tried
them the other day for the first time i
tried all three flavors blue raspberry
summer ice and cherry limeade i liked
them all
but i will say the summer ice was on top
and you can get it delivered right to
your door right so you don't have to
even leave the house you can just have
this the good vibes at home you can just
float in a floaty on a lake
with your summer retro icicles get a
hammock
and more will come right to your door so
how do you do that you go to bud
light.com delivery or this might be
another fun option you go pick it up at
the local neighborhood grocery because
you can walk and get out get out in the
sun
you can go to a convenience store liquor
store support local business people like
that regardless of how you procure it do
yourself a favor and get these things in
your hands and eventually you're going
to want to get them in your mouths but
start with the hands
[Music]
you also say that it's virtually
impossible to die from psilocybin and
and it's not addictive um and i remember
growing up in health class they you said
psychedelics are far more frightening to
people than they are dangerous i
remember that being um
that was such a powerful lesson uh that
we were taught such propaganda in health
class that you know you hear and these
anecdotal
examples of
somebody somebody who's dealing acid i
remember that one and they were pushed
into a pool and they now think that
they're a glass of orange juice uh in a
mental institution you know they're
afraid they're gonna be pushed over
but those things are indelible to me you
know they they scared the [ __ ] out of me
oh yeah they were incredible uh
propaganda stories about lsd and i
believed them all frankly i was
terrified of these drugs because i i
came of age by the time i came i was
conscious of lsd and other psychedelics
the backlash had begun and the stories
you you heard were that lsd scrambled
your chromosomes
or uh caused you to think you could fly
and you would jump off of a building and
kill yourself sure and then another one
uh that was reported in the news
was that a group of college students on
lst stared at the sun till they all went
blind
absolutely not true completely made up
out of whole cloth and um but these
stories are still
in the culture yeah well an art link
letters account right and that one is an
open question because we don't know and
right we don't know that she had lsd in
her system or that she had even taken it
but that's what he claimed and that was
a powerful story i'm sure there are
people who who committed suicide on lsd
i mean people are reckless and and take
drugs in the wrong setting setting and
that these drugs these drugs are very
powerful and need to be used with great
care
and young people sometimes are reckless
in the way they use them i mean everyone
is reckless sometimes that backlash
though was very powerful it was like a
moral panic and um
and i too had that fear but before i was
willing to try psychedelics for the book
you know i was i was a grown-up i was
almost 60 and i wanted to make sure that
i wasn't doing something really stupid
so
i looked at the risk profile and i was
amazed at what i found i mean the first
was as you said
you can't overdose on the classic uh
psychedelics there's no known lethal
dose that's a that's a remarkable fact
because
you know
the tylenol in your medicine cabinet
which you bought without a prescription
has a lethal dose it's like 20 pills or
something like that it'll destroy your
liver um so it's very rare that a drug
doesn't have a lethal dose
and then the other fact that amazed me
is that they're not habit-forming um you
know and in the same you know that
classic set up where you put the rat in
the cage and they have these two levers
and one administers cocaine to its
bloodstream sugar and the other is sugar
and they'll press the cocaine over and
over and over again until they're
addicted or they die yeah um if you do
that with lsd the rattle press once
check it out once and never again oh
really yeah they'll just climb over the
whole thing they'll they don't you're
out of the way yeah i mean you can
imagine it'd be hard to understand what
was going on if you were a rat it's hard
enough as a human
rights right well that's the other that
brings me to another fear i would have
and i wonder if you had just about you
talk about bad trips that they are very
real um but i i didn't realize that what
they usually call psychotic breaks for
are just short-lived panic attacks but
was that a concern yes i i didn't know
you know i think we're all afraid of the
interior of our own psyche to some
extent like what what might come up what
might we find this is a sure terra
incognita and i was worried that yeah
some awful [ __ ] would come up and i
don't know what it was but some deep
dark secrets in my existence not ready
for recovered trauma and some people do
recover traumas and yeah and that can be
really destabilizing and that's one
reason why
if you're gonna have a high dose you
should have somebody with you you should
not be alone you should have a sitter or
a
or a therapist ideally and um
that's the key you talk about set and
setting being really important and in in
the studies they've been doing uh the
ones that a thousand of whom have had
been properly dosed they said there were
there were very few adversities and
that's because this is optimized i mean
this set and setting is optimized you
have two guides with you the whole time
they've prepared you very carefully i'm
talking about in the you know the
official drug trials um they they tell
you what to expect they tell you what to
to do if something scary happens which
is really important
so for example if you're if you feel
like you're going crazy or dying or
melting go with it don't fight it the
key thing is to surrender to what's
going on in your mind and if you do that
you'll pass through into a much happier
place if you if you cling to your ego as
it's collapsing
and defend yourself you're going to get
really anxious and and that's how you
have those anxiety attacks
some people do have there are the
occasional psychotic break in people who
are at risk for schizophrenia and that's
and that those people are are not
allowed to participate in these trials
um but um but when you're you know when
you're well prepared when you're guided
by somebody
when you have someone to help you make
sense of what happened afterwards
there don't appear to be any adverse
events that doesn't mean people don't
have scary episodes um right but the
researchers won't call them bad trips
they call them challenging trips because
like a nightmare it's it can be very
useful to unpack it and kind of figure
out what it has to say
and and i've heard that it comes up
you'll you'll feel flashes of it or
you'll feel the effects of it months
later i i've a lot of friends who've
done ayahuasca and they say that's the
case and that also is is a concern but
also like this is probably very
beneficial potentially yeah you know
this whole phenomenon of acid flashbacks
um is not that well documented there's a
couple scientific articles about it
i mean
when we think about that we think about
going back into a full-blown
hallucination
and that doesn't seem to happen or not
happen very much but there are powerful
memories that do come back um but you
know it's not like you know they disable
you in any way they're just kind of
powerful recollections and and they're
various images from my journeys that uh
i i dwell on from time to time they'll
pop into my head and i'll think about
them and what do they mean but
it's not a problem um right
in the way we relive episodes from our
lives all the time
and so it felt because you said i
sounded like we think very differently
about we have similar
anxieties we we're
um
i i don't know that you said you didn't
consider yourself spiritual necessarily
you were you were a realist um
yeah you said you're you're often
thinking about the future you said the
good thing is i'm rarely surprised the
bad thing is i'm rarely surprised i love
that line
so you're going into this peyote
experience with that mindset how do you
divorce yourself from that mindset how
do you go in uh in as neutral as open a
way as possible
well
um i first of all i didn't do peyote i
did psilocybin um oh okay peyote is a
very complicated uh
one to deal with partly because it's
um you know it's used by native
americans in their in their religious
practice and there's no and there's a
shortage of it and i think the real
questions of whether non-natives should
use it since there are other ways to get
mescaline
and that's the chemical produced in
peyote but my my powerful experiences so
far have been on
psilocybin
and um
i prepare myself by remembering these
mantras that that my guides have taught
me and and the researchers you know like
surrender
surrender to whatever happens
whatever happens
bring this question to it what do you
have to teach me whatever's going in my
mind i want to know what you have to
teach me so it's it's going in with a
spirit of openness um
not
having an intention that's so narrow
that you know this is what we're going
to work on because it won't necessarily
happen
um
and you know some deep breathing
and relaxation techniques
but i have to say every time i've done
one of these journeys
i've had a sleepless night before of
anxiety i mean i i don't go into it like
yeah let's go give me the give me the
pill give me that mushroom
yeah um no every time it's like a leap
into the dark and um
it's funny that these are you know
considered recreational drugs because
they're actually hard work um it's
they're not it's not an easy experience
and afterwards you're often exhausted
you may be elated but you're exhausted
it's like you run a marathon
and um and you don't immediately want to
do it again i understand why it's not
habit forming because it's it's it's a
big experience that you need to recover
from and process for a while
so you know emotionally michael
emotionally
yeah no emotionally it's like what did
that mean what did that is i mean
why was i dwelling on that person in my
life i didn't expect to um
so
it's
you know it's it's just it's a
consequential undertaking and the idea
that you just pop you know you know a
tab of acid and go to a concert i mean
that may work for some people but um
it's it's risky and not as interesting i
think is going into it with this sense
of intention uh to really learn
something about your mind
intention yeah um
you you talk about an experience you had
at a dinner party um
a woman was talking about her
experiences uh on acid and
and um you it piqued your curiosity
because of the it sounded so beneficial
um was was was that the first time you
really started
was that the first time you remember
thinking like this could be something
for me or i want to explore well that
that episode
you know i had had very little
experience of psychedelics myself
and here i was at this very grown-up
dinner party in the hills of berkeley
and and this was a prominent professor
uh who was in her 60s talking about
using lsd and then i listened a little
more closely and i realized she's just
she's not talking about when she was in
college she was talking about last week
and
and i was like wow that's interesting
and yeah and she's a psychologist and
she's she's saying it was really
interesting it taught her very
interesting things about the mind and
she and she's the one who said you know
this this consciousness feels very much
like the consciousness of children which
is what she studied right and um and
that made me think that
that this the psychedelic story wasn't
over and that it wasn't just a 60s
episode
and that there might be a
this might be a time to look at it again
and indeed i dug a little more and i saw
there was a renaissance of psychedelic
research which had been moribund for
like 30 years
and you say carl jung as having said
that it's probably more beneficial in
fact to people uh
in their middle age than it is to young
people yeah and i there's a line in the
book where i say um you know it may be
that psychedelics are wasted on the
young
um
and and the reason for that is that you
know when we're older we were talking
about habits before when we're older our
habits the grooves of habit are deeper
and deeper and deeper and we have all
these kind of
programs we run for every situation in
life based on what worked last time yeah
and um
but habits you know as i say you quoted
me you know take us away from living and
they're they're very programmatic
they're not alive to the moment
right and so what's i think the most um
powerful therapeutic use of psychedelics
is they break habits
they temporarily suspend them
when they suspend the ego because it's
the ego that enforces habits on us
and then
that gives an opportunity for new brain
connections to form
new ways of new perspectives news ways
new ways of doing things
and if you think about all the people
who are helped by psychedelics these are
people with depression anxiety obsession
addiction
they're all crippled and anorexia
nervosa looks like may respond to
there are people who are crippled by
habitual thought or behavior
and you know for the depressive it's
it's this habit of thinking that i'm
worthless or life is is
is worthless for the addict it's the
behavior that i can't get through the
day without a cigarette or or a drink
um and
psychedelic seems very helpful in
breaking those habits and um and that's
remarkable because we don't have
remember we don't have we don't have
many tools for that
right i i read a study about a man who
was who had experienced such a
deep uh horrible trauma it was his
mother his mother was murdered in front
of him
you may have read about this recently
and um nothing worked i mean he was he
was uh
had struggled with substance abuse over
the years but but
nothing seemed to have worked and and he
started doing this program um
involving psychedelics and uh
and they they attacked the trauma he saw
the trauma he was able to kind of
re-experience the trauma and um
and
i guess relive it or do something with
it his brain did something with it that
uh that enabled him to then
function without needing other
substances without needing alcohol yeah
i know there's some i mean i i've
interviewed many many people who've had
transformative experiences and wow and
how amazing is it that a single um
experience with a drug should change a
lifelong pattern i know um and without
you know a pill you have to take every
day um and all the problems that come
with that and
it is i mean it is quite miraculous and
you know we and we still don't totally
understand it
life could be a dream
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vied for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
why is there now so much more research
being done you talk about three events
that happened in 2006
is there a way to unpack that quickly
for people just so they know a little
bit about the history of why now why
this has come to the forefront so after
nixon launches the drug war the funding
dries up for psychedelic research it was
never actually prohibited but
it became stigmatized scientists didn't
want to go near it there was no money to
do it
but there was a group of people who
never lost faith in the potential of
psychedelics it was heavily researched
in the 50s by psychiatry and and and was
regarded as a very promising treatment
for mental disorders and for addiction
um
and
this small group of people clung to this
passion for for psychedelics and they
waited for
the moment when they could bring it back
um and they started uh and there was a
change in management at the fda also the
food and drug administration and someone
came in
uh who was in charge of drug approval
who who announced basically i mean
quietly to researchers that they would
henceforth treat psychedelics like any
other drug there would be no special
problem with studying if you had a good
study they would allow you to do it and
beginning in the early 90s they let a
couple people do some studies one the
first was with dmt by a psychiatrist
named rick straussman and then a little
later in the decade
a group got a formed out in california
um
uh
uh and bob jesse who's a who's a hero in
my book um who was a former tech
executive who who had a powerful
experience with psychedelics and really
wanted to see them return to research
he raised some money and
found a very good researcher at hopkins
who he
interested in it and
and connected him with a guy a therapist
who'd worked with psychedelics back in
the 70s
and they got together and started um
started this research
your journey quitting caffeine tell
people about that because that's
something most people can relate to or
not relate to or not relate to yeah so
in this book in in uh this is your mind
on plants which is looking at these
three
plants uh plant-based psychoactive
chemicals um
i wanted to and it's also a look at
drugs what are drugs
um
and you know the drug war is ending it's
coming to an end and we have to figure
out what we think about these and how
we're gonna fold them into our lives or
not fold them into our lives
um because the government will no longer
decide for us and i think that's a very
good thing
but
i don't think people think about
caffeine as a drug
but it is the most widely used
psychoactive on the planet 90
of people
use caffeine daily
um
it is a drug it changes our minds it
changes uh our consciousness and in
subtle ways it's more transparent
certainly than a psychedelic or than an
opiate
we feel very clear but get off it and
you'll realize very quickly that your
normal consciousness is caffeinated
consciousness
wow and uh i was actually interviewing
one of the researchers one of the
psilocybin researchers at hopkins roland
griffith
and before he got involved with
researching psilocybin he was the the
world's leading caffeine researcher
so i was interviewing him about that and
at some point he said you know the only
way to understand your relationship to a
drug that you use is to get off it
so he challenged me to quit caffeine
cold turkey which i did for three months
and it was one of the hardest things
i've ever done
it's amazing what was the first what
initially what was it just the
withdrawal symptoms described it well
that that first day you know there's
this this lifting of the mental fog upon
waking you know that the caffeine gives
us we're like we're back to baseline
and what that is is the withdrawal
symptoms which all of us undergo all of
us who are addicted to caffeine undergo
beginning when we wake up
are stopped by that first sip um and and
that's why that first sip is so
important
if you don't get that first sip uh or
that second sip you feel kind of foggy
all the time
i felt
like i had add
normally my powers of concentration are
pretty good
and uh but suddenly like
stuff from the periphery was interfering
and i couldn't i couldn't stay on track
with anything i was doing whether i was
reading spotlight yeah the spotlight was
disabled yeah and um and i think that is
one of the real benefits of caffeine it
intensifies the spotlight
and that's why it allows us to get so
much done it's why people are more
productive on caffeine than without it
well that was another interesting uh
part of your book that i thought i
didn't know the history behind caffeine
and how coffee was introduced in the
17th century and it coincided with i
mean it was really a tool for capitalism
yeah
the effect that it had socially it was
an amazing tool for capitalism what you
have to remember is before caffeine
the main drug was alcohol and people
drink morning noon and night
instead of water you say it was safer
than water because it was fermented and
um so people they were you know people
would give their kids like hard cider
for breakfast and uh oh my god and
everybody was in this slightly fogged
state of you know
buzz and um you can't really have an
industrial revolution when everyone's
everyone's a little like a little uh
loaded it does yeah yeah but
you can have a play you can have a
bubonic play there's also probably how
you can have
but um but when caffeine comes to europe
and as you said it's in the 17th century
there's a real change that that is
perceived and and you really get the
before and after and suddenly you have
um
interest in rationalism and and the
enlightenment and capitalism and the
proof of how important caffeine is to
capitalism comes with the institution of
the coffee break i mean think about it
your employer your employer gives you
time off
and gives you a drug to enjoy during
that time
what's the catch what what is he or she
doing well yeah they know full well that
you will perform better
uh after a coffee break and this is this
was proven in the 50s
and so um yeah it's it's the uh it's a
great drug for extracting more labor out
of your workers
um michael were you hesitant to go back
on it after you had i mean you had gone
no i couldn't wait i just couldn't wait
oh
okay i mean in a way part of my
experiment i wanted to see what it would
be like to be off it but i also wanted
to see
what it would be like to get back on and
have that first cup
and yeah it was psychedelic i mean it
was oh i bet it was so powerful like a
punch in the face and it almost made it
worth it to get off because that that
first cup was so much so euphoric and i
bet and i became almost compulsive in
getting getting stuff done i i went home
i had this first cup and we sat in a
cafe and i was like so happy and then
suddenly i got a little compulsive and i
said i got to get some stuff done i got
to go home
and uh so my wife and i walked home and
i went right to my computer and uh i
started cleaning my desktop and then i
then i unsubscribed from like a hundred
listservs that were really bugging me
yeah i've always wanted to do that and
you never have the time but you never do
no yeah i just knocked them down one
after another and then i went to my
closet and organized my sweater uh shelf
um so you know i really had the benefits
of caffeine what was said is that i
can't you can't hold on to that power
because
very quickly you get addicted again and
i tried for a while i had this rule that
i would only have caffeine on saturdays
and that was that worked for a while i
was um you know i would really look
forward to saturdays and that cup of
coffee would have all that power
but over time it's like oh i got a
deadline on thursday i think i'm going
to move it up
right well you're chasing this thing
that's the interesting thing about the
psychedelics the non-addictive
properties of those
psychedelics that that you just harness
the the benefits yeah and and um
and leave it at that that's really yeah
although people who microdose with
psychedelics you know they have to be
careful not to build up tolerance in the
same way
because thank you right and that's why
um micro dosing usually take off uh you
know it's one day on two days off
uh-huh um running out of time and i'm
sorry to be uh so abrupt but i'm so
curious about too many things uh if you
had to of course people know uh
you you've written so much about food
and
and uh and gmo
how how
you know how
poisonous that is uh if you had to give
me advice on the best way to eat how
would you sum it up would it be mostly
plants only eat meat from farms uh yeah
in a nutshell so well yeah i mean my um
my seven word advice is eat food
not too much
mostly plants
right by eat food i mean eat real food
eat food like your great-grandmother
would recognize it as food uh eat food
that is
as close to its natural state as
possible not yes not edible food like
substances which is a lot of what is in
the supermarket these days oh well and
that's often what i get when i get
snacky i i really love weed and i
you know it's
the the reason i can't smoke too much of
it probably among other things is really
too much is that it makes me ollie too
much uh do you ever get
do you ever you know just break down and
you have any guilty pleasures like that
oh yeah all the time i have a weakness
for uh nuts and crackers and bread i'm
carbohydrates i'm pretty crazy i don't
have a sugar tooth but i have a i have a
fat tooth i you know i love cheese um
but um yeah i mean not too much is the
hard part um yeah what is too much um
but i think if you kind of try to be a
little more mindful on your eating
most americans eat until they're stuffed
um
but other countries always have other
cultures have this rule that you should
eat until you're four-fifths full or
two-thirds full
i mean the french you know don't say are
you full
when you're talking to your kid they say
um
is your hunger gone
um
and that's a very different moment so
eat eat yeah eat until your hunger is
gone
not until you're stuffed and oh that's
great yeah that's hard to do it's very
hard for americans
especially when you're first stoned
americans um
all bets are off
right right you just pull the rip cord
would you uh would you do ayahuasca
again michael or is that too do we not
have time to answer that
yeah i guess i would under the right
circumstances i've never done it with
indigenous uh you know with a shaman and
i think that would be a very interesting
experience if i had the occasion um yeah
yeah i mean i would be open um i still
have i still feel like i have things to
learn from psychedelics right um that
it's a long journey it does you know you
don't get the you don't get the whole
story uh at once
and ayahuasca is a very interesting
substance and it's it's a challenging
one i mean a lot of people have very
dark experiences on ayahuasca
yeah but i would curiously be open to
the idea
well um i we're gonna talk so much about
the book and the outro the intro but it
is fascinating this is your mind on
plans uh it's out now july 6 but wink
wink it's out now um we have uh a
lightning round question which now it'll
be an actual lightning round uh because
you have so little time yeah i got a
couple minutes what do you got
okay thanks michael um i'm embarrassed
to ask you this but it's just part of
the thing it's a procedure what is your
most commonly used emoji would you say
[Music]
uh it's it's this it's the thumbs the
thumbs up yeah or the smile or a smile
um if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play
baseball
uh mets yankees um
i
well i grew up a mets fan because i grew
up on long island but long enough right
but when they sucked as bad as they
sucked i switched over to the yankees i
don't believe in hanging in with a
shitty team
so uh-huh well so you're talking to a
jets fan so uh obviously
we don't think the same yeah i know yeah
so yeah i don't have that insane
nationalistic loyalty
okay okay if you could have one snack
food for the rest of your life uh what
would it be what is your go you
mentioned cheese
uh snack food snack food it would be
almonds
almonds or peanuts roasted yeah yeah raw
roast no roasted no salt roasted no salt
hey me too uh what does you usually ask
a movie question but i want to tailor it
a little bit because of course uh
tracy palin's your sister of course
tracy's married to my hero michael j fox
uh
it's good thing we don't have time
because i i don't have time to gush
about him but um you or he mentions you
he talks very lovingly about you in his
last book uh what is your favorite
excluding back to the future your
favorite michael j fox movie
he might listen to this yeah i know i
know just know that yeah um
i i mean i was going to say that one
yeah well you know all right i have to
make it it was kind of a bomb but i
thought at the time i thought bright
lights big city was great oh
great i love brightly speaking great
book keeper's other one uh what is yours
speaking of drugs uh all about that what
is your uh if you do
ever sing karaoke uh if you've ever gone
through karaoke bar and if you haven't
what would your go-to song be and yeah i
know your friend is waiting and this
kills me i don't know be some beatles
song probably
yeah oh good um
your first celebrity crush
linda ronstadt okay uh if you had to get
a tattoo what would you get
it would be too hard to answer it would
be a vine
crawling up my arm or leg oh a tendril
very tender um
what is your favorite fruit
favorite fruit uh blueberries and who
would you want to play you in your
biopic like the pollen story
michael j fox
oh god yeah me too hate me too
i'm a lot taller than you yeah
okay oh now i hope we i really hope he
listens to this um
dogs or cats do you prefer uh i've been
a cat person
and um you mentioned the beatles uh we
usually ask beetles with the rolling
stones but i'm curious about your
favorite beatles song now if you if you
could put one on right now what would
you have a hankering to hear
here comes the sun
okay well that's appropriate um uh you
have been every the sun is shining on me
i get to talk to you thank you michael
justin and i love talking to you
such a pleasure thank you for the extra
time and and for all of your great work
uh we uh i can't wait to talk about the
book to everyone i meet all right well
thank you very much i really appreciate
it great talking to you take care
[Music]
well that's well that just happened
i don't know what i'm doing
it's the there's not much there's not no
no he's a little uh pretty neutral
neutral yeah but he's uh he's got a
great voice i really love because i was
listening to his book on audible
not a they are a sponsor but that wasn't
an ad i just said audible i can say that
sure um yeah he's got really there's
something very soothing about and he
narrates his books really well narrates
reads hmm what would you say i would say
i would say reid yeah okay you know he
is
a combination of i think extremely
intelligent
and
very cool yeah and i think that
combination yeah
is
quite rare
and not to generalize people but i'm
going to generalize people you know
often you see like jeopardy winners you
know people who are extremely
smart and knowledgeable
they tend to
be a little less social
socialized a little bit goofy socially
um
however i'm thinking of some you know oh
yeah i mean most
i mean yeah most really impressive
jeopardy winners are maybe not the
coolest socially uh-huh
yeah however he is
seems very cool cool like he'd be um
like a cool hang really fun to hang with
at a cocktail party you know when he
mentioned that woman that he
who was talking about her experience
drug experiences at that cocktail party
i thought like oh man it'd be fun to
hang out with him and then when you add
not to dwell on this but when you add
his sister and his brother-in-law how
cool they are he'd be a
he'd be a good friend to have
and how
he lived in connecticut too he's in new
york he was in new york but i think he
lives in connecticut he lives in
connecticut oh boy he [ __ ] he he has a
garden he gardens i know he does drugs i
know
he does drugs friend goals he really
he really is
that's my he has access to michael j fox
oh my god forget it it'd be that's the
only friend i would really need no
offense to my friends listening no
friends no friends
james and togo i hope they're listening
i bet they are
thanks for listening guys
if you are shout out i admire your
restraint with him really yeah well i
wanted to hear him talk i expected more
gushing book reporting i expected more
book reports
i mean don't brag there was some of it
there's some moments
don't gloat
there was some chris farley moments we
like remember when you said um in
chapter seven when you said uh it's so
good though it's like i wanted to quote
him he deserves to be quoted it's almost
like you want
him to know that i don't respect it yeah
yeah i do that you read not only read
his material but
absorbed it digested it and took the
time to remember it yeah i did i did
i wanted him to it's not the most
exciting for listeners how about when he
said he was like i said is it daunting
for you to be doing these
to unpack all of because it's those
books that and i also i made the mistake
of like starting the previous one after
i read this recent one just because i
was so interested in the origins of it i
came downstairs and you had scribbled
like a million little notes on and i
before the interview i got nervous i got
nervous i thought oh [ __ ] this is going
to be
this is going to be really tricky to
listen because that's usually uh
precedes
uh you're just regurgitating a lot of
yeah it's like i i know all this stuff
now but there was so much good stuff
it's one of those books where i found
myself writing down at like every other
line from because there's such great
insight into the the human mind yeah
it's really fascinating oh it's
fascinating he is as a person he is such
a good argument for
you know dipping your toes
in those psychedelic waters i know i
know and he makes a
very you're right he himself is a
compelling case for but
you read these books and it's like oh
it's like kind of a no-brainer i was
telling mom about it um
i was i was trying to
you know sometimes i i feel like she
could really benefit from certainly from
marijuana but she'll never do it she'll
never do it um
but at the very least cbd
you know which is not at all
it has no psychotropic effects um but
she won't even try that so i don't think
she's gonna be doing mushrooms anytime
soon i would i i've always been too
scared to do but you know what she said
to me sorry to interrupt she said uh she
said oh i hope you don't do that uh-huh
and i was like but i'm telling you all
these like positive things about it i
just read the book and i was talking
about silas how they're giving it to
people to help with their traumas their
mental health they'll likely be
disappointed listening to this
conversation for sure she'll be
disappointed with the intro in fact i
was as you were talking i was thinking
oh what would our parents say about that
they'd probably be ashamed i know they
would be ashamed
yeah yeah because
the stigma is still so of course which i
i understand yeah yeah i didn't know
that about nixon and oh man early i mean
i knew nixon was a turd but i didn't
know yeah i didn't know that that was
fascinating that his motivation among
other things was to he thought that if
kids were exposed to uh lsd it would
make them less
uh desirous to go to vietnam yeah yeah
and he may have been right yeah i mean
it may have had a real yeah yeah i know
but also how about that that that
ehrlichman it was earlier right who said
their two the public at their public
enemies that they were
that they were going after were black
people and the hippies and in order to
do that they had to take away their
their drugs of choice
and they criminalized it which is still
having it's brilliant it's like evil
evil i mean you know it's so it's so
smart i know so shitty i know it's
really sinister yes like like i know to
your point i knew he was a turd too but
i didn't know how dirty i mean that's
another level that's not tur that's like
right this is dark it's off topic but if
you watch ken burns vietnam series oh
it's amazing
oh i know i know i know and kissinger
like beyonce i know like evil evil i
know
like
yeah i mean craven craven
many many many people died for his own
ambition yeah and his ego what he what
he withheld god god that's a great
series yes
yeah there's a great uh maybe future
guest
not nixon
i was like wow
not if he's listening to this that that
that's
incredible we jump to shark when we have
richard nixon on the show yeah we uh
same alma mater no no a moderator it's
not an almond matter if i didn't
graduate right faster yeah i don't think
so well wait oh ken burns went there i
think so i didn't know that i'm pretty
sure really
are you sure i don't think so oh maybe
i'm confusing with lisa kudrow
oh yeah she went to bastard that's how
funny that i want to watch the friends
reunion so bad really
your eyes are fast that's a tough word
you know my school doesn't always be
cool people uh alums as yours does well
that's not fair to say yeah
cool what do you mean cool like uh then
noteworthy who do they have andy rooney
oh he's a he's an older piece
well i don't like this i don't like
podcasts with two people with no
experience in journalism talking about
things they don't know anything about
that's my andy rooney impression that's
good i don't like podcasts it's a little
disrespectful because he is
no longer with us well i don't like uh
mortality all of this breathing and
cellular activity well i want to be a
spirit in the nether regions
um but that was interesting what he said
about um psychedelics how it removes
your um
your habits in a way so yes so it like
takes your ego away and and as a result
you become
like hyper present yeah in a way that
you can't do normally i i thought that
was in a way that you can't be normally
well it's and the idea that we are
conditioned our brain has set up certain
certain ways of dealing with reality
just to make things easier so we're not
i guess so we're not like overthinking
everything see that's my big problem
with marijuana that as much as i enjoy
it sometimes like a lot enjoy it
sometimes i veer into paranoia and i get
kind of stuck in a cycle of
um negative thoughts in my head that i
can't get out of
and when he said that thing about
leaving
lean into it and just accept it and and
if you just go with it and you don't try
to control it
that's when you have a good experience
and
and that's how i am with weed too like
if i'm feeling myself getting paranoid
or weird
it's always effective when i tell myself
give into it well as i think you can
apply that lesson to things in life too
i was talking to my friend about
pain dealing with pain and the
difference between leaning into pain and
like confronting it and um and sitting
in a suffering
you know sitting just being just
suffering and not confronting the pain
properly
that's i think that's how you grow i
think that's how you
you break through i think you that you
can apply that same logic yeah to things
like pain trauma
what are you saying about caffeine was
really interesting how i know 90 i
didn't realize it was that high 90 but
there's something very depressing about
the fact that he went off for three
months and he didn't feel like himself
felt like he was in a fog he couldn't
concentrate i was hoping he would say
like oh yeah by month three it was like
feeling good again i know but he was so
eager to have another cup i know but but
it's he's honest about it yeah that we
are
totally addicted as a culture we're
totally addicted to this drug i've
noticed that with weed if i if i go off
it for a little while which i did
when i just did i just worked in
arkansas as people are probably sick of
hearing about and um i know i am trying
it again it it really hit me i mean it
was really like a yeah and like i i felt
that with coffee too if you don't know a
couple days without and you once you
have it again it's amazing
you know i used to smoke cigarettes in
my youth and i remember if like a week
would go by when i didn't have any and i
had one again it was the best oh yeah
again yeah you get the tingly yeah yeah
my god that does it really powerful drug
yeah sure that's why it's it's
interesting to live in this society that
like why should uh um lsd why should
psylocybin be so st you like saying that
oh because i want to make sure i keep it
in my head so i think i'm overusing it
it's not because you're proud that you
can you know it yeah maybe it's not just
no i think i'm just trying to keep it in
there because i really like i i want to
learn more about this stuff and um i
like talking about it it's interesting
it's interesting it's fascinating the
fact that these plants i know can and
how they adapted that way it can give us
a whole new perspective on ourselves on
the world
unlock these amazing and how about that
study i don't know if we
i think we did talk about this how they
gave um
they gave silocybin to um
people with terminal cancer
and that the majority of them i think
were no longer afraid of death wow when
you think about it
this way it's kind of
um
it seems really stupid
to live your whole life and not i know
try experimenting at least a little bit
with some of these things it feels very
limiting
that these things exist as scary as you
know
they are and as much stigma as it has
and
and you might have a negative experience
on them if you don't do it correctly or
whatever but
um still it seems like the benefits the
potential benefits of it and like what
it can unlock in you
really outweigh all those potentially uh
potential pitfalls i know i was thinking
that when i was talking to mom that she
because i know she never will because
she was so
uh and i i'm afraid of doing it myself
and i think i'm a lot more open to those
things i know i am but um i thought god
how sad you know that she's gonna
go the rest of her life without
not potentially using
the whole expanse of her mind and her
mind's full potential
there was something kind of like
so limiting about that not to sound
condescending but um
that but my fear about ayahuasca you're
limited too i sure am i don't know
whether to say certainly or sure you
certainly am
um my fear with ayahuasca is well it's
twofold vomiting the vomiting yeah the
vomiting and the pooping you poop too
apparently like whatever comes out comes
out and you have to like have a thing
nearby and i'd be more afraid of the
vomit i hate vomiting in front of people
too because it's such a vulnerable kind
of thing let's read a letter okay
okay
here we go letter time
should we have a little thing for
letters uh letter it's letter better
time better time
better time well okay
from taylor parker uh subject hello life
would be a dream if you read me oh hello
justin and christian i'm taylor from
north texas have fun with my unisex name
taylor yeah well i will taylor this
feels so weird to write to you although
i doubt this will actually be red
wow
i wonder why she doubted that or he or
he right uh-oh unisex taylor taylor
parker this feels so weird to write to
you although i doubt this will actually
be red justin i've been a fan of your
for a long time my comfort movies are
all of your 2000s classics oh my god
classics that's sad
so old you have a shakespeare way of
delivering a monologue that is
phenomenal huh that is so
shakespeare might
might take issue with that comparison uh
not the mention you're not to mention
your effortless comedy and wits oh thank
you taylor what a nice letter so far so
far i want to say this because i don't
think you give yourself enough credit oh
interesting obviously this podcast
brings me so much joy as a newly mother
of two
who worried way too much about parenting
siblings to hear how close you christian
and your family are gives me hope that
my children and family will remain close
to
i didn't grow up with a family so i
worry about my children a lot i am so
thankful for this bright spot in my week
when i get to laugh and smile as i get
through my mundane chores and the pile
of homework as i work on my never-ending
master's degree wow good for you taylor
good lord
i listen so much my toddler knows and
dances along to the songs ah i wish i
had a cooler letter like the lady who
played her grandmother's recording boy
did she set the bar yeah that was a
great letter but so is this don't sell
yourself short taylor your advice to me
i turn around on you anyways thank you
boys for this podcast and for all of
your work over the years it truly put a
smile on a lot of faces i cannot wait to
see what you do next yours truly taylor
man
that was nice i love letter time well
september 17th lady of the manor yes
that's next yes uh check that one out
and um i guess the toddlers can see it
right well there's a little drug
i don't know if the topic yeah maybe not
the toddlers yeah there's some curses
swears yeah that's a disclaimer yeah um
finally some oh good some would you
rather thank you taylor would you rather
have all traffic lights you approach be
green or never have to stand in line
again that is great i think we have had
that we have yeah i think so
um i would uh rather
never stand in line again me too
you know why i don't not why um but
i don't mind
in fact i kind of like the fact that
there are red lights meteor driving i
don't i wouldn't want to always
red lights give you a chance to
stop composed
i agree i don't mind because it's also
like you're sitting and you're listening
to music probably
it's uh i like driving too me too i
don't remember standing in line
you're exposed you're near people yeah
um
you're standing to be as pleasurable
sitting
uh i definitely i don't mind red lights
i've been red lights red lights green
lights i've been a lot more chatty in
line lately i've noticed i've been
enjoying talking to people though and
really yeah and talking to um check out
people
maybe i've always chatted with check i
guess so i i maybe i've just
been more so or i've gone back to my old
self because i'm feeling a little bit
more confident about the waning days of
the pandemic you're also a double
vaccine i know i don't want to brag
again about that but you haven't had the
two weeks yet have you oh not quite oh i
have ha ha oh you have yeah man safe
yeah okay i think i know who knows who
knows what they put in me i know uh okay
that's a great one though taylor um
yeah i'd definitely rather uh not wait
in line and would you rather
also i always choose the worst line to
wait in i am so if you ever see me in a
line with like multiple line choices go
in another one because i i guarantee you
i will be in the slowest one
bad line terrible line luck you have to
be a little more surgical about
why what line you choose you know like
you have to see who's in front of you
i've gotten good at this
it's not so it's not so much the amount
of items they have
or the amount of people in front of you
it's more
what type of people there yes and you
have to anticipate
how
uh
fast or slow they're going to be
yeah that's what i think i have a hard
time reading right
yeah i think you just look at them
you're not too loyal to the
general numbers you know like oh there's
there's three people right now two
people this line
um yeah you got to take in more you have
to thin slice these people thin slice
yeah um okay hopefully a future guest
malcolm gladwell oh yeah that'd be great
in fact i thought that was happening no
i don't know um maybe now that we had
michael pollan yeah whether it's
incredible yeah would you rather have a
pause or rewind button in your life i'm
assuming pause doesn't mean like
everyone's frozen i oh i thought it did
oh i i interpreted that more as like you
can hold on to the present moment longer
and not like everyone's i'd rather have
literally pause i'd rather have the
pause button if that's the case
you can hold on if that's not the case
and everything was just like awesome i
wouldn't want that no
but if it is just holding on to the
present longer
i would want that here's the thing about
rewind uh when you when you're older
i'm guessing i shouldn't speak for you
but i'm going to probably want that a
lot more
you know whether i mean and how far back
can you rewind you already want it
yeah right yeah i mean you i'd like to
read you wax poetic about your
younger years i do but i wouldn't want
to rewind to them
you know i wouldn't want to because it
might be frustrating that you get that
reminder and you see your youth and your
innocence and yeah you can't have it
yeah also i'm quite content with like
my age now i know maybe it doesn't sound
like it all the time but if faced with
the reality of going back i'd rather
hold on to the present me too you don't
both want to have to want to hold on to
the present that's crazy
um okay but great thank you taylor
really good ones um i was just thinking
too about you know if malcolm gladwell
uh were on for us to passively
aggressively uh will malcolm gladwell on
uh what are the odds that monkey j fox
is listening to this because marco
pollen who's the guest
do you think he listens to all of his
brother-in-law's
podcast
no idea what if i had to make a wild
guess you'd say no
no i would say he would be listening to
this because i
i know he follows you on instagram yes
very exciting very exciting
um so he will see you posting about this
and he'll probably think oh that's my
brother-in-law
and
my acquaintance justin and they're
talking
and um yeah and i'm guessing
on your instagram post you're going to
mention
michael j fox oh i was wondering i was
going to ask you i was going to ask you
a note and you're going to use that as
bait to try to get michael j fox solicit
yes i do think he's listening would that
be lame and desperado to mention my
fights in the post i don't no no no
because you like him
it comes from a place of love it does it
sure does and slight desperation
okay well as long as the love outweighs
yeah i think it does yeah uh so i hope
he is so michael kind of it'd be great
to is this i mean your conversation with
michael pollan is was very interesting
so i for that alone forget what we're
doing now
i think
mr fox would have really enjoyed that
just doesn't it sound like
i i know it's respectful to call
somebody mister something or are you
aging him and aging him it sounds like
weirdly
uh i don't know what it doesn't sound
right mr fox he's also
mike i don't know he seems like the kind
of guy in fact
when i worked with him i think he was
like michael i mean everyone called him
michael mm-hmm there's something about
the he also has such a youthful energy
you know that like to call him mister
it did sound weird once you left my
mouth yeah anyway thanks to taylor
thanks again for writing we can address
all this when michael is a guest on the
show yes the white whale yes and if you
would like to write in our email
addresses life is short wondery.com and
thanks again to our distinguished
very impressive guest michael pollan oh
and everyone please read do yourselves a
favor read this is your mind on plans
and his previous work how to change your
mind just and the omnivores dilemmas oh
man
he's written a lot yeah and they're all
like
page turner i know really truly you'll
be scribbling
notes like crazy seriously yeah so thank
you to him and um
and to his sister tracy pollen for uh
choosing uh
just the best mate
and uh and all your work on family ties
i used to love them together on family
ties too um anyway uh oh and uh well i
was gonna plug family ties the the
episode where his friend dies
yes that's a good one um anyway
christian's rolling his eyes i think
that means it's time to end the show i
think you're right life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
follow life is short on apple podcasts
amazon music the wondery app or wherever
you're listening right now listen ad
free by joining wondery plus if you like
our show please give us a five star
rating and a review and be sure to tell
your friends another way you can support
the shows by filling out a small survey
at wonderee.com
survey life is short is hosted by me
justin long it's co-hosted and produced
by you christian law it's also produced
by megan v monaco senior producer is
michelle me lans audio engineer today
and every day is sergio enriquez and the
executive producer is
marshall louis for a company called
wundery
[Music]
patrick ewing has a 37 year old son 37
yeah
um do you know what patrick ewing's
middle name
is how did you know that
how the hell did you know that
how did you know that i don't know
i was about to say like that's a crazy
thing to ask you
how the [ __ ] did you know that
i can't believe you knew that patrick
aloysius ewing
i can't either just like popped in
that is crazy
what do you like that's like scary
actually that you knew that well i
listened to the fan a lot
when did they say his middle name on the
fan patrick aloysius ewing
uh
i must have heard it
wow goes to fall asleep listen to the
fan all right yeah i did you both have
to fall in sleepless with a fan
i used to fall asleep listening to the
fan and to uh to mike francesa and to um
fox the 95 9 the fox yeah the late late
shows
steve summers steve summers yes oh my
god yes
yes the schmoozer
that's so crazy uh do you know michael
jordan's middle name since you're so
into like nba grades middle names
uh yeah i do um
uh
michael jeffrey jordan oh my god
how do you know these things
that's so weird
how do you know middle name so well of
nba legends
okay wait a second wait a second do you
know charles barkley
you